l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire de la proposition de loi
visant instaurer une majorité numérique
et à lutter contre la haine en ligne
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
marquant Gely rapporteur de la
commission mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame et Monsieur
les ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires culturelles
mes chers collègues permettez-moi avant
de d'ouvrir cette discussion de me
joindre au propos de madame la
Présidente en tant que père de famille
la mort d'un jeune homme quel que soit
les circonstances ne peut jamais laisser
totalement
indemne et j'ai une pensée pour les
proches de ce jeune homme
mes chers collègues le temps est venu
pour notre assemblée de conclure un
processus législatif entamé il y a
maintenant six mois lorsque j'ai déposé
cette proposition de loi je ne pensais
pas qu'un tel consensus se ferait jour
aussi bien dans notre hémicycle que sur
les bancs de la Haute Assemblée
cela m'a conforté et démontrer que le
Parlement sait être au-delà des clivages
partisans le lieu de l'intérêt général
la vitesse avec laquelle nous nous
sommes saisis de ce texte et le signe
d'un changement d'époque nous autres
législateurs avons collectivement pris
conscience des dangers créés par les
usages précoces d'Internet et somme
décidé à agir pour protéger nos enfants
un corpus juridique nouveau est en cours
de construction à l'échelle européenne
d'abord avec le rgpd le DSA et le DM1 à
l'échelle nationale ensuite avec la
proposition de loi visa à lutter contre
les dérives des influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux la proposition de loi
visant à garantir le respect du droit à
l'image des enfants et le présent de
texte par ailleurs nos collègues
sénateurs examineront cet été le projet
de loi visant à sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique qui contient des
mesures ambitieuses pour faire
d'Internet un espace plus sûr je pense
notamment à la lutte contre l'exposition
des mineurs au contenu pornographique
certes internet est un progrès ainsi
qu'un formidable espace de liberté accès
à la culture à la connaissance lieu
d'échange et de rencontres ces
opportunités sont nombreuses et nous les
reconnaissons tous à ce titre je salue
l'introduction d'une disposition visant
à exclure du champ d'application de la
proposition de loi des encyclopédie en
ligne et à but non lucratif tels que la
plus connue d'entre elles Wikipédia
mais comment ignorer pour reprendre le
mot de ma collègue rapporteur du Sénat
et promesse non tenues d'Internet ces
risques je les ai exposés en détail
fausses informations cyber-harcèlement
addiction des socialisation baisse de
l'estime de soi et encore d'autres les
suicides de jeunes adolescents exposés
sur les réseaux sociaux à la moquerie à
la calomnie au déchaînement des passions
les plus ordides se multiplient Marion
Chanel Lucas Lindsay combien de prénoms
de jeunes collégiens cyber-harcelés par
leur père devons-nous encore lire dans
les gros titres et je ne parle même pas
des invitations à des défis dangereux ou
des standards de beauté inatteignables
sources de mal-être
nous ne pouvons plus regarder ailleurs
nos concitoyens ne le comprendraient pas
ils ne le comprennent pas notre devoir
de législateur est de protéger nos
enfants de même d'abord en mobilisant
les parents première responsable de la
sécurité et du bien-être des mineurs
c'est là tout le sens de la démarche
initiée responsabiliser les parents et
les impliquer dans la vie numérique de
leur enfant alors que près de 80%
d'entre eux déclarent
ignorer ce qu'ils font réellement
d'Internet avec l'article 2 de la
proposition de loi les entreprises de
réseaux sociaux devront recueillir le
consentement de l'un des parents lors de
l'inscription à leur service qui
pourront par la suite réclamer si
nécessaire la suspension du compte du
mineur de moins de 15 ans un principe
simple une règle simple
nous nous sommes accordés en CMP sur le
texte issu des libérations du Sénat dont
je salue la qualité de travail sous
réserve de quelques modifications
rédactionnelles ce texte me paraît
équilibré préserve pleinement le niveau
d'ambition initiale je suis bien
conscient qu'il ne pourra suffire à lui
seul à mettre fin au dérive d'Internet
nous devons avancer sur les techniques
de vérification de l'âge en ligne et
investir massivement dans l'éducation
numérique pour les parents les enfants
ou encore les enseignants je sais que le
gouvernement est conscient de ces enjeux
et nous aurons l'occasion d'un débattre
madame et monsieur le ministre lors de
l'examen du projet de loi présenté par
le ministre chargé de la transition
numérique
aussi mes chers collègues je vous invite
à adopter cette proposition de loi aussi
largement qu'en première lecture et vous
en remercie par avance
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame Isabelle roche
Vice-Présidente de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur cher Laurent Marc Angeli mes
chers collègues je tiens au premier lieu
à remercier le rapporteur pour son
initiative qui a permis à la
représentation nationale de ce
rassembler autour d'un grand enjeu de
société l'accompagnement de la
transition numérique j'en suis convaincu
la révolution numérique qui se déploie
sous nos yeux est un bouleversement
anthropologique majeur et constitue l'un
des plus grands défis de notre époque le
rapporteur l'a rappelé Internet est
d'abord un espace de liberté pensons par
exemple à la toux qu'on représente les
réseaux sociaux pour des peuples en
lutte dans la conquête de leur liberté
notamment pendant les printemps arabes
hélas le monde numérique est aussi un
espace de menaces multiples qui pèse
d'abord sur les mineurs les parents
d'ailleurs ne citeront pas puisque selon
l'association y enfance 75% d'entre eux
estiment que leurs enfants risquent de
faire une mauvaise rencontre ou de subir
du cyber-harcèlement
sur les réseaux sociaux selon la même
association 20% des enfants ont déjà été
confrontés à une situation de
cyber-harcèlement il s'agit d'un
phénomène de société à part entière qui
ravage des vies et détruit des familles
les exemples sont nombreux et tout aussi
insupportables les uns que les autres et
je pense bien évidemment à la faire mida
qui a suscité une immense prise de
conscience dans tout le pays mais aussi
plus récemment au suicide de l'Insee
dans le Pas-de-Calais accablé d'injures
sur les réseaux sociaux
ceux-ci ont leur part de responsabilité
qui a d'ailleurs été reconnue de façon
inédite par la justice britannique dans
le cadre de la ferme Moly Russell cette
jeune fille assaillit de contenu
relatifs à l'automutilation et au
suicide ainsi été poussé à l'isolement
et à la dépression
l'objectif que nous devons poursuivre
est simple et néanmoins ambitieux rendre
à Internet sa vocation initiale un outil
au service de l'humanité en l'espèce le
législateur a écouté toutes les parties
prenantes et à trancher en faveur de la
préservation de l'épanouissement des
enfants le rapporteur nous a mis en
garde la présence proposition de loi ne
pourra suffire à elle seule à faire des
réseaux sociaux en espace sûr et réguler
cependant elle apporte à l'édifice une
pierre indispensable en faisant le choix
de ne pas inscrire dans la loi une
technique de vérification de l'âge
plutôt qu'une autre le rapporteur a
adopté une logique pragmatique des
solutions techniques sont nombreuses et
inégalement fiables et respectueuse de
la vie privée aussi le texte s'en remet
pour élaborer un référentiel à l'arcom
et la CNIL deux autorités dans la
maîtrise de sujets complexes et
techniques n'est plus à démontrées
je partage pleinement cette approche qui
permettra à la France de s'adapter
efficacement à l'évolution de plus en
plus rapide des technologies disponibles
cette proposition de loi consacre des
garde-fous non pas des garde-fous
institutionnels qui seraient du ressort
de l’arcome de l'acné du gouvernement ou
du Parlement mais des garde-fous
familiaux relevant des parents et je
rejoins pleinement le rapporteur dans sa
volonté de remettre l'autorité parentale
au cœur du dispositif de production des
mineurs sur Internet dans ce domaine
comme dans les autres l'État et l'école
s'ils peuvent beaucoup ne peuvent pas
tout les mineurs de moins de 15 ans ne
pourront plus s’inscrire de façon
autonome sur les réseaux sociaux le
consentement des parents devrait être
expressément recueilli ici il s'agit là
d'une avancée majeure qui sera
pleinement effective après que l’arcome
aura mis en place le référentiel dont le
législateur lui a confié les déborations
cette proposition de loi n'est ni la
première ni la dernière à aborder la
protection des mineurs en ligne le
caractère évolutif d'Internet nous force
à régulièrement adapter notre
législation et nous devrons à l'avenir
remettre l'ouvrage sur le métier
nous le ferons cet automne avec l'examen
du projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique qui
complétera notre harceleur arsenal
législatif alors que le règlement pour
les services numériques doit entrer en
vigueur en septembre le rapporteur a
mentionné les mesures de lutte contre
l'exposition des mineurs à des contenus
porte
ma part la peine complémentaire de
suspension de l'accès à un service de
plateforme en ligne qui donnera la
justice une arme supplémentaire pour
réprimer la haine en ligne et le
cyber-harcèlement et je forme le vœu que
notre débat sur ce projet de loi soit
aussi riche et fécond que celui que nous
avons su faire vivre dans notre
hémicycle sur la proposition de loi de
notre collègue Laurent Marc Angeli je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrault ministre délégué chargé de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre mesdames
et messieurs les députés nous voici au
terme du parcours législatif de ce texte
qui fera date et je veux remercier et
féliciter le Président Marc Angeli
d'avoir été à l'initiative et d'avoir
accompagné l'adoption de ce texte en
quelques mois seulement car nos enfants
ne pouvaient plus attendre car nos
enfants sont les principales victimes
des travers de la société numérique
surexposition aux écrans
addiction aux réseaux sociaux
cyber-harcèlement exposition précoce à
des contenus inappropriés autant
d'attentes d'atteinte brutale à leur
innocence autant de violences
psychologiques faites à une génération
qui menace d'être sacrifiée si rien
n'est fait il nous faut donc agir et
depuis quelques années nous agissons et
la France sur ce sujet de la protection
des mineurs en ligne montre la voie
grâce à la loi Studer la France sera
bientôt le premier pays du monde à
généraliser le contrôle parental sur
l'ensemble des équipements vendus sur
son territoire
grâce à la loi Balanant les plateformes
ont depuis 2022 l'obligation de lutter
contre le cyber-harcèlement scolaire sur
leur plateforme
grâce à la mobilisation du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale du ministère de
l'économie et des finances tous les
élèves de 6e bénéficieront dès la
rentrée prochaine du passeport numérique
qui est sensibilisera aux gestes à
adopter au risque auquel ils peuvent
être confrontés en ligne grâce à
l'engagement de Madame la Ministre de
l'enfance et du ministre des Solidarités
un site internet a été créé je protège
mon enfant.gouv.fr qui recense toutes
les informations dont peuvent bénéficier
les parents pour les accompagner dans la
parentalité numérique c'est-à-dire dans
la manière dont ils peuvent accompagner
leurs enfants dans l'espace numérique
et sous l'impulsion du Président de la
République en 2022 a été adopté le
Règlement sur les services numériques un
règlement européen qui fait enfin entrer
les grandes plateformes de réseaux
sociaux dans l'air de la responsabilité
avec des obligations d'ordre général
l'obligation de modérer les contenus
illicites sur leur plateforme de faire
auditer leurs algorithmes de partager
leur donner aux chercheurs ce qui leur
permettra de mettre en avant les les
dérives que nous dénonçons aujourd'hui
mais également des obligations et des
interdictions nouvelles visant à
protection protéger les enfants en ligne
et en particulier la publicification de
conditions générales d'utilisation
facilement compréhensible pour les
enfants
l'obligation de garantir le plus haut
niveau de sécurité de sûreté et de
protection de la vie privée des enfants
et puis enfin l'interdiction de faire de
la publicité en ligne ciblée sur les
enfants l'ensemble de ces obligations
ces obligations d'ordre général et
celles qui visent plus particulièrement
les mineurs seront SAN ctionnés
d'amandes pouvant aller jusqu'à 6% du
chiffre d'affaires mondial
voir d'un bannissement en cas de
manquement répété vous le voyez mesdames
et messieurs les députés depuis quelques
années la France a montré la voix mais
il nous faut aller plus loin aller plus
loin avec le projet de loi visant à
réguler et sécuriser l'espace numérique
dont l'examen a commencé hier en
commission spéciale au Sénat et dont
l'assemblée nationale sera saisie à
l'automne avec des mesures qui ont été
citées par monsieur le rapporteur en
particulier des pouvoirs confiés à
l'arcom pour ordonner le blocage en
quelques semaines des sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifieront pas
l'âge de leurs utilisateurs mais aussi
des sanctions pour les hébergeurs qui ne
retireront pas les contenus
pédopornographiques qui leur seront
signalés par les services de gendarmerie
et de police aller plus loin avec ce
texte cette proposition de loi portée
par Laurent Marc Angeli qui va imposer
désormais aux réseaux sociaux de
vérifier l'âge de leurs utilisateurs et
lorsqu'ils ont moins de 15 ans de
s'assurer de recueillir le consentement
de leurs parents c'est absolument
fondamental car la vérification d'âge à
l'entrée sur les réseaux sociaux et la
mère des batailles et je veux remercier
les députés les sénateurs qui ont
travaillé sur ce texte en veillant à
tout instant à ne pas détricoter le
Règlement sur les services numériques
que la France a porté et en veillant par
ailleurs à ne pas déposséder l'autorité
parentale des responsabilités qui sont
les siennes et je constate qu'après une
adoption à la quasi unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale une adoption à
l'unanimité au Sénat que la CMP c'est la
commission mix paritaire c'est prononcé
à son tour à l'unanimité sur ce texte
c'est la démonstration éclatante que
lorsque l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
est en jeu le Parlement c'est trouver
les voies du consensus alors en
remerciant une dernière fois Laurent
marquant d'avoir pris cette initiative
en l'assurant que nous veillerons avec
Charlotte cobel à la bonne application
de ce texte j'appelle évidemment je vous
appelle Mesdames et Messieurs les les
députés à voter très largement pour ce
texte que le gouvernement soutient
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Charlotte cobel
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'enfance
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la vice-présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous y sommes la
majorité numérique devient un principe
et l'autorisation parentale une
condition d'accès aux réseaux sociaux
bien conscient les impacts positifs mais
aussi des risques extraordinaires de la
révolution numérique que vous avez tous
très bien décrit le président de la
République a posé comme priorité de son
second quinquennat la protection des
mineurs en ligne
cette ambition nous l'apportons
collectivement gouvernement et Parlement
au sein du comité interministériel de
l'enfance la première ministre a fixé à
tout le gouvernement la protection des
enfants dans l'environnement numérique
comme un des cinq sentiers prioritaires
dès lors tout le monde s'est engagé au
sein du gouvernement dans ce combat
Jean-Noël Barrault et moi-même
travaillons sans relâche avec les
plateformes pour renforcer leur
responsabilité réguler les contenus
inadaptés retirer les contenus illicites
afin de protéger les enfants
des réponses très concrètes sont aussi
apportées dans le projet de loi
numérique qui est actuellement en
discussion au Sénat pour renforcer
encore et toujours le cadre légal et
réglementaire qui s'imposent aux
plateformes et qui garantit ainsi une
plus grande sécurité aux enfants
d'autres ministres Jean-Noël barreau l'a
dit sont également engorieux à nos côtés
en particulier bien évidemment le
ministre d'éducation nationale j'y
reviendrai par la suite mais ce combat
nous ne pouvons pas le porter seul nous
devons le mener avec vous à l'Assemblée
nationale avec le Sénat
plusieurs textes ambitieux visant à
garantir le bien-être de nos enfants et
le respect de leurs droits ont été
présentés devant votre assemblée à
chaque fois le gouvernement a été à vos
côtés
nous avons évoqué les trois propositions
de loi de Bruno Studer dont certaines
sont entré évidemment dans la
législation visant à encadrer le travail
des enfants influenceurs à instaurer un
contrôle parental par défaut et
maintenant à protéger le droit à l'image
des enfants sur Internet nous avons
répondu présent sur la proposition de
loi d'Erwan Balanant sur le volet
numérique du harcèlement scolaire nous
avons répondu présent sur la proposition
de loi de Caroline janvier visant à
prévenir les risques de l'exposition
excessive aux écrans et à former les
professionnels nous avons répondu
présent et donc c'est tout naturellement
monsieur le Président Charles Laurent
Marc Angeli que nous avons répondu
présent à ce très beau texte que vous
nous avez suggéré
en tant que secrétaire d'État chargé de
l'enfance je m'y suis également engagée
personnellement car depuis un an dans
l'exercice de mes fonctions j'ai pu
mesurer l'inquiétude des parents
grandissante elle nous remonte au
quotidien sur les réseaux sociaux
justement où je suis régulièrement
interpellé dans les courriers que nous
recevons et dans le cadre de
déplacements sur le terrain et
évidemment cette inquiétude fait écho au
drame récent que nous avons connu et que
vous avez évoqué comment élever nos
enfants sereinement quand Lucas dinal
Insee et vous avez donné bien d'autres
prénoms et malheureusement d'autres se
sont donnés la mort parce que leur vie
était devenue insupportable à cause du
harcèlement scolaire et du
cyber-harcèlement eux qui commençaient à
peine leur adolescence
deux notions d'ailleurs que nous ne
pouvons plus séparer il n'y a pas de
harcèlement scolaire sans
cyber-harcèlement il y a en fait du
harcèlement sharcèlement qui touche à
tous les instants de la vie de l'enfant
en tout lieu sans arrêt le harcèlement
qui existe à l'école et le ministre
d'éducation nationale et pleinement
mobilisé pour enrayer ce fléau mais ce
harcèlement qui dépasse l'école nous
aurons bientôt des propositions qui
complèteront l'ensemble du programme
porté par le ministre d'éducation
nationale pour bien montrer que ce
phénomène dépasse l'école et qu'il nous
faut tous y répondre
les réseaux sociaux ont donné un nouvel
écho en effet à la violence qui est dans
notre société y compris entre les
enfants en gravant tout ça dans l'espace
numérique
ces phénomènes nous devons les affronter
ensemble gouvernement et Parlement mais
nous devons emmener les parents avec
nous pour qu'ils prennent la mesure ou
continuent à prendre la mesure que le
numérique est au cœur maintenant de leur
parentalité
c'est pour cette raison d'ailleurs que
Bruno au Suder très logiquement a choisi
de mettre le numérique dans l'exercice
de l'autorité parentale j'aime
d'ailleurs mieux parler de
responsabilité parentale avec la
proposition de loi visant instaurer une
majorité numérique et à lutter contre la
haine en ligne au-delà du principe posé
par la proposition de Monsieur Studer
nous complétons le dispositif avec un
repère très clair pour les parents et
pour les enfants avant 15 ans les
enfants sont trop jeunes pour évoluer
seul dans l'espace numérique ils doivent
être accompagnés avant tout par les
parents eux-mêmes et pour les parents
nous devons faire des règles simples
lisibles et des repères extrêmement
clairs ils doivent aussi être
accompagnés par les adultes et de
manière générale et par les
professionnels et c'est pour ça que nous
nous engageons aussi à renforcer la
formation des professionnels
évidemment j'ai bien conscience comme
vous vous l'avez tous dit que nous
n'allons pas tout résoudre avec la
majorité numérique mais ce texte j'en
suis sûr doit créer va créer une
dynamique le triple d'abord une
dynamique une dynamique au sein des
familles en ouvrant un dialogue entre
les parents et les enfants qui
n'existent pas aujourd'hui oui par an
sur 10 disent ne pas parler avec leurs
enfants de ce qu'ils font sur Internet
là où ils vont demander à leurs enfants
même assez tard où vas-tu quand ils
sortent de la maison il ne demande rien
aux enfants sur le numérique la majorité
numérique et la responsabilité des
parents va les amener à entrer en
dialogue avec leurs enfants
une dynamique je l'ai dit à l'école
aussi et dans les lieux d'accueil des
enfants dans la logique que vous portez
mais aussi que porte le texte de
Caroline janvier et j'en suis sûr une
dynamique collective et sociétale il
doit nous donner l'occasion de nous
interroger bien sûr sur la pratique de
nos enfants mais pardonnez-moi sur la
pratique de nous adultes tant elle
impacte aussi la pratique de nos enfants
sur le numérique cette dynamique
monsieur le Président grâce à vous et
enclenché je suis sûr qu'elle va
continuer et qu'il nous faudra
l'entretenir parce qu'il nous faudra
régulièrement nous adapter à l'évolution
du numérique qui souvent a une longueur
d'avance votre proposition de loi
propose une brique essentielle la
majorité numérique est une pièce
maîtresse de la stratégie que nous
menons avec force autour du président de
la République c'est pour cela que j'ai
pleinement soutenu votre projet que je
me suis engagé pour qu'il aille au bout
du processus législatif je sais Monsieur
le Président que je pourrais toujours
compter compter sur vous pour protéger
les enfants dans la vie réelle comme
dans cet espace virtuel si plein de
promesses mais aussi de risques merci
beaucoup merci
nous débutons la discussion générale
avec Madame Agnès Carrel pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
Laurent mes chers collègues nous
arrivons au terme de la navette
parlementaire de cette proposition de
loi qui à l'Assemblée Sénat comme au
Sénat a été marqué par un consensus il
faut protéger les plus jeunes des
dangers que peuvent représenter les
réseaux sociaux au nom du groupe horizon
et à parenté je tiens à saluer le
travail et l'engagement du président
marquantelli sur cette question si
importante et structurante ce texte
répond à un double défi de santé
publique et de protection de l'enfance
en instaurant l'obligation par les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux de mettre
en place une solution de technique de
vérification de l'âge des utilisateurs
et du consentement des titulaires de
l'autorité parentale pour les moins de
15 ans
cette solution devra être certifiée par
les autorités en cas de manquement une
amende pourra être infligée à
l'entreprise allant jusqu'à 1% de son
chiffre d'affaires mondiale après une
mise en demeure de l'arcome ce texte est
le fruit d'un consensus heureux au sein
de la commission mixte paritaire entre
nos deux assemblées je tiens à saluer le
travail de nos collègues sénateurs qui
ont également participé à enrichir ce
texte sur le plan de l'information
d'abord nous sommes convaincus de la
nécessité d'imposer aux réseaux sociaux
la délivrance d'une information adaptée
aux mineurs de 15 ans sur les risques
des usages numériques et sur les droits
informatiques
les plateformes devront être également
devront également activer un dispositif
permettant de contrôler le temps
d'utilisation de leurs services lors de
l'inscription 20 mineurs et informerons
régulièrement l'usagé de cette durée par
le biais de notification
nous le savons tous ici comme parents ou
même comme grands-parents nous mais
aussi comme élu régulièrement interpellé
sur ces sujets dans nos circonscriptions
que les mineurs organisent désormais une
grande partie de leur vie autour de ses
réseaux sociaux devenant rapidement
addictifs je ne rappellerai pas les
chiffres effrayants de l'utilisation
précoce de ces réseaux par les enfants
cette proposition de loi répond à un
besoin urgent les récents drames de nos
jeunes adolescents victimes de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ont abouti à des suicides ces derniers
mois ne peuvent que nous rappeler d'agir
sans délai et en tant que législateur ce
texte remet les parents devant leur
responsabilité et surtout leur donnent
les moyens de protéger leur enfant
c'est dentarité exposition à la violence
ou à de fausses informations baisse de
l'estime de soi risque de dépression
harcèlement incitation à la haine
troubles de l'attention et du sommeil
troubles des apprentissages mais aussi
incitation à la chirurgie esthétique les
preuves scientifiques de lien de
causalité entre l'utilisation très jeune
et druides des réseaux sociaux et la
santé mentale et même physique des
enfants et adolescents s'accumulent les
études menées un peu partout dans le
monde ne cesse de nous appeler à agir
face à l'ampleur des risques il convient
donc de prendre des dispositions que
nous n'avons pas su hélas anticiper
jusqu'à présent
même si nous en avons conscience ce sens
chantier ambitieux n'en est cassé début
et qu'aucune mesure n'est infaillible il
est temps que la France affiche grâce à
ce texte une réelle volonté de protéger
nos enfants des effets néfastes de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux cette
proposition de loi non seulement
à protéger vise non seulement pardon à
protéger sinon à alerter les moins de 15
ans mais permet aussi de sensibiliser
les parents de rappeler et de rappeler
que les enfants ne sont pas les seuls
menacés d'embrigadement sur les réseaux
sociaux
ce texte est donc un premier garde-fou
devenu primordial face à la précocité
croissante de la puberté numérique et à
la puissance des outils mis à
disposition de la jeunesse le groupe
horizon se félicite que l'initiative de
son président est trouvé un écho unanime
auprès de notre assemblée et de nos
collègues du Sénat et votera bien
évidemment ce texte qui replace l'enfant
et sa protection au cœur de nos
préoccupations
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Francesca
Pasquini
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les drames qui ont émaillé
l'actualité depuis le début de cette
proposition de loi doivent nous rappeler
combien il a nécessaire de légiférer
pour faire respecter la majorité
numérique et lutter contre la haine en
ligne monsieur le rapporteur vous l'avez
vous-même exprimé le défi est de taille
et notre travail sur ces questions ne
serait s'arrêter ici malgré les
désaccords qui existent entre nous il
est heureux que nous puissions avancer
vers un encadrement des acteurs privés
vers un respect des droits numériques
des mineurs et vers une meilleure
protection de ces derniers au moins 2
millions d'enfants sont directement
concernés par les mesures proposées
aujourd'hui les données de la CNIL nous
indiquent en effet qu'au moins la moitié
des enfants de 10 à 14 ans sont déjà sur
un réseau social
ces 2 millions d'enfants sont la cible
d'entreprises qui ont fait recettes de
l'hyperconsommation de contenu de
l'enfermement enduit par les algorithmes
de recommandations et finalement des
données personnelles de leurs
utilisateurs nous ne pouvions pas
continuer à laisser des entreprises
privées décidez elles-mêmes des mesures
qu'elles mettent en place pour assurer
un usage sain de leur service par nos
jeunes concitoyens pour répondre à cette
exigence un travail sérieux a été
effectué par les deux Chambres la
version adoptée en commission mixte
paritaire est à l'image de ce travail
équilibrée et satisfaisante chers
collègues puisque l'issue de ce vote
fait peu de doutes je couperai court au
suspense pour venir dès à présent que le
groupe écologiste nupes votera ce texte
je préfère profiter du temps qu'il me
reste pour vous partager une inquiétude
profonde qui ne remet pas en cause notre
soutien au dispositif proposé
les modifications apportées à la
présente proposition de loi au cours de
la navette bien que constructive montre
néanmoins les limites de ce texte et le
travail titanesque qu'il reste à faire
sur l'éducation au numérique certes nous
pouvons nous réjouir qu'à travers cette
loi les députés de la majorité proposent
et votes des mesures qui contraignent
les entreprises mais nous devons
pourtant nous inquiéter et regretter
qu'au sein de ce texte nous nous en
remettions exclusivement aux réseaux
sociaux pour informer nos jeunes sur les
usages les droits et les bonnes
pratiques du numérique faut-il s'en
remettre à ses entreprises pour délivrer
je cite une information sur les risques
liés aux usages numériques et les moyens
de prévention et une information claire
et adaptée sur les conditions
d'utilisation de ces données et ses
droits garantis ou encore pour informer
régulièrement l'usager de son temps
d'utilisation par des notifications
comme cela a été ajouté au texte
faut-il faire confiance à ceux qui ont
créé les mots contre lesquels nous
combattons aujourd'hui pour les endiguer
la réponse nous semble évidente nous ne
le pouvons pas les l'éducation numérique
et le levier le plus efficace et le
moins inégalitaire pour s'assurer que
les générations à venir les futures
majeurs numériques soient bien formés et
informés loin d'apporter un soutien à
ces politiques d'éducation au numérique
force et de constater que le texte que
nous nous apprêtons à voter aujourd'hui
est un petit traité de techno
solutionnisme les réseaux sociaux se
sont développés en dépit de notre droit
pas d'inquiétude une solution technique
les fera rentrer dans le droit chemin
les jeunes utilisateurs font un usage
immodéré des réseaux sociaux n'ayez
crainte une notification les avertira
les mineurs sont exposés à des contenus
non adaptés sur les réseaux sociaux nul
appréhension à avoir un message affiché
dans l'application les éclairera sur les
moyens de son prémunir n'est-ce pas
ironique chers collègues cette
démonstration ne vaut pas rejet des
mesures que vous avez proposé monsieur
le rapporteur ces solutions techniques
dans ton scrutera assurément la mise en
place en France mais aussi au-delà de
nos frontières nous faisons le vœu
qu'elles soient efficace mais chacun
peut déjà prévoir quels seront
insuffisantes alors monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre chers
collègues nous espérons sincèrement que
votre volonté de protéger les mineurs
sera aussi vigoureuse lorsqu'il faudra
soutenir l'école je vous en remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Soumia bouroua du
groupe Gauche démocrate et républicaine
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les députés communistes et le
groupe GDR soutiennent ce texte tel qui
suit des travaux conjoints de notre
assemblée du Sénat dès la première
lecture nous avions fait part de la
nécessité de légiférer et d'instaurer
une majorité numérique notamment pour
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux c'est
avec lucidité que nous appréhendons ce
texte en sachant très bien qu'il ne
pourra régler à lui seul les enjeux si
importants que sont ceux autour de la
régulation de la régulation du numérique
c'est en sachant aussi que les solutions
technologiques ne sont pas encore
matures et que nous sommes constamment
engagés dans une course de vitesse entre
elles et leur nécessaire régulation mais
toutes les limites technologiques ne
doivent pas nous empêcher de légiférer
sous le prétexte que cela sera vain
c'est même tout le contraire car nous ne
pouvons nous en remettre à la simple
bonne volonté de ces entreprises
remettre à demain des avancées que nous
pouvons obtenir aujourd'hui serait une
erreur et c'est d'ailleurs dans ce même
état d'esprit que nous abordons nous
aborderons la loi sur le numérique dont
le débat débute au Sénat
sur le fond du texte nous soutenons le
principe d'une majorité numérique et le
fait de le fixer à 15 ans c'est tout
d'abord en raison de sa cohérence avec
ce qui se pratique pour le rgpd en effet
un mineur peut consentir seul à un
traitement de données à caractère
personnel en ce qui concerne l'offre
directe de service de la société de
l'information à compter de l'âge de 15
ans il est donc en capacité de procéder
à une transaction de nature
contractuelle comme il le fait en
s'inscrivant sur un réseau social l'âge
de 15 ans est également l'âge retenu par
la CNIL mais celle-ci précise que cette
position n'en est née ni un laisser
passer général donné aux mineurs né un
blanc sain accordé au fournisseurs de
services en ligne pour contracter avec
des mineurs comme il le ferait avec des
adultes je crois que ce point est
essentiel quant aux obligations des
fournisseurs de services des réseaux
sociaux qui doivent être beaucoup plus
vigilants quant aux que leur activité
peut engendrer chez les enfants
rappelons les chiffres les principaux
chiffres 82 % des enfants de 10 à 14 ans
navigue de manière régulière sur
Internet sans leur parents de plus 63%
des enfants
âgés de moins de 13 ans ont au moins un
compte sur un réseau social Instagram
rassemble 58% des 11 14 ans et 89% des
15-18 ans et snapchat
75% des 11 14 ans et
88% des 15-18 ans quant à Tik Tok
atteint plus de 50% d'utilisateurs chez
les 11-18 ans je m'excuse de tous ces
chiffres
cyber-harcèlement exposition à la
pornographie pratique dangereuse si
l'État peut contraindre les réseaux
sociaux et autres sites à être proactifs
dans la modération des contenus le rôle
des parents reste primordial pour
contrôler et éduquer les enfants au bon
usage des réseaux sociaux sur la
prévention du cyber-harcèlement
sur ce qu'il faut partager ou non les
parents ne sont pas plus de 50% à
décider du moment et de la durée de
connexion de leurs enfants et 80%
déclarent ne pas savoir exactement ce
que leurs enfants font sur Internet ou
les réseaux sociaux nous voyons ici
l'ampleur du travail qu'il reste à
engager enfin et nous le verrons lors de
la loi sur le numérique l'articulation
entre plusieurs impératifs et parfois
délicates jusqu'où porter atteinte à la
vie privée au nom de l'intérêt général
comment vérifier l'âge par des
dispositifs qui ne soient pas trop
attentatoires à la vie privée par
exemple ce texte laisse quelques regrets
malgré mon notre soutien le montant de
l'amende pour les fournisseurs de
services de réseaux sociaux qui ne
respecteraient pas leur obligation n'est
que de 1% de leur chiffre d'affaires
cela nous paraît sous dimensionner pour
réellement apparaître comme une
contrainte pour ces entreprises
plus généralement l'impact des écrans
sur nos enfants doit devenir l'un de nos
sujets prioritaires c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi plusieurs par le menteurs dont
je fais partie et habitantes et
habitants de nos circonscriptions se
penchent actuellement sur cette question
dans le cadre d'un forum citoyen ainsi
nous sommes bien conscients des limites
mais surtout des avancées que nous
propose ce texte et en espérant qu'il
s'accompagne d'un mouvement plus large
pour mieux protéger nos enfants les
députés GDR voteront une nouvelle fois
ce texte je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe
hypertindépendant outre-mer et
territoires
bien madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
nous discutons cet après-midi de la
proposition de loi visant à instaurer
une majorité numérique j'aimerais pour
être rapide puisque nous allons soutenir
ce texte revenir sur deux aspects le
premier un peu sur les avancées mais
aussi sur les lacunes de ce texte le
texte initial a donc été remanié pour
tenir compte des différentes positions
la rédaction au sortir de la commission
mixte parité fait ainsi l'objet d'un
accord entre les deux assemblées
naturellement nous saluons cette entente
mais regrettons que le dispositif
n'aille pas plus loin d'abord ce texte
ne s'appliquera pas uniquement aux
nouveaux comptes ce qui existe déjà
seront tout autant concernés cette
extension du périmètre de la loi issu
d'un amendement déposé par le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires a été conservé en commission
mixte paritaire et nous nous en
réjouissons
nous regrettons néanmoins que le texte
actuel reporte cette mise en conformité
en effet les plateformes disposeront de
deux ans pour vérifier l'âge de leur
utilisateur et encore cette période ne
commencera qu'après la promulgation de
la loi c'est à dire après l'avis de la
Commission européenne sur la conformité
du texte avec le droit communautaire
ensuite nous pensons que les
parlementaires auraient pu aller plus
loin et inscrire dans la loi
l'interdiction pure et simple aux
mineurs de moins de 13 ans d'accéder aux
plateformes en ligne
pour nous cette disposition
est une enfin cette disposition voir
dans cette disposition pardon une
restriction de l'autorité parentale est
excessif et notamment
uogar au danger les dangers liés au
harcèlement à la pédo qui criminalité ou
encore à la désinformation ne sont pas
écartées par un simple accord parental
nous devrions nous assurer que c'est
l'usage même des réseaux sociaux qui est
adapté aux mineurs et nous craignons
donc que les parents acceptent que l'on
enfant est un compte sans pour autant
surveiller leur pratique cette mesure
d'interdiction pure et simple ou mineur
de moins de 13 ans était aussi la
meilleure façon d'empêcher la collecte
de donner personnelle pour les moins de
13 ans exigences naturellement du
règlement général de la protection des
données
troisième et dernier regret le périmètre
de la pppl les forums de discussion les
plateformes de communication des jeux
vidéo les plateformes de streaming ne
sont pas plus protecteurs que les
réseaux sociaux classiques
ne pas être certain que ces réseaux
davantage d'ailleurs utilisé par les
jeunes soit concernés par le présent
texte pourrait apparaître comme un oubli
ou une méconnaissance de légistes du
législateur je pense notamment au forum
à discord ou à touch
mais nous sommes et vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur sur une première
base sur un la pose d'un garde-fou et il
nous conviendra rapidement
d'intensifier notre réflexion sur cette
problématique et naturellement cela va
passer par des négociations au niveau
européen car il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui techniquement il sera
facile pour des jeunes de se soustraire
à notre législation au s'inscrivant sur
d'autres territoires par ailleurs il
faudra aussi poursuivre les politiques
au niveau humain et financier concernant
l'éducation électronique des jeunes mais
aussi des adultes
et par ailleurs comme les faits de
harcèlement sont omniprésents dans cet
univers il conviendra aussi de renforcer
les sanctions pénales à l'encontre de
leur hauteur ceci dit nous tenons à
saluer le travail du Président Marc
Angelique qui a porté ce sujet au sein
de cette niche de son groupe et qui
constitue véritablement une première
marche une première pierre pour un
travail que nous allons devoir dans les
mois et les prochaines années
poursuivent car si cet univers est
merveilleux il est aussi un poison et
notamment pour nos jeunes pour cela le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires soutiendra et votre
majoritairement pour ce texte merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame Béatrice Piron
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues permettez-moi tout d'abord
d'exprimer ma gratitude envers Laurent
marquantelli président du groupe horizon
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
pour cette emparée de la question
cruciale de la protection de notre
jeunesse dans l'environnement des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui l'effet sont
indéniables 82 % des enfants âgés de 10
à 14 ans navigue régulièrement sur
Internet sans la supervision de leurs
parents
63% des moins de 13 ans possèdent au
moins un compte sur une plateforme
sociale en violation des règles établies
il en découle que nos enfants sont de
plus en plus exposés à un âge précoce
aux écrans et donc au contenu
inapproprié qui peuvent rencontrer sur
ces réseaux de plus cet usage massif du
numérique par les jeunes mal informés et
souvent mal accompagné contribue une
fine au développement du
cyber-harcèlement 20% des enfants et
adolescents déclarent et avoir été
confrontés de vraies mesures sont donc
indispensables pour enrayer ce phénomène
grandissant face à toutes ces dérives la
majorité a mis en oeuvre depuis le
précédent mandat plusieurs mesures
visant protéger notre jeunesse je
citerai la loi de 2018 relative à
l'encadrement de l'utilisation des
téléphones portables dans les
établissements scolaires ainsi que
l'initiative plus récentes de 2022 qui
facilite l'accompagnement des parents
sur Internet grâce à l'installation par
défaut d'une solution de contrôle
parental sur les équipements vendus nous
avons également instauré l'enseignement
du numérique dans les établissements
scolaires du primaire au lycée
conduisant des certifications telles que
le permis Internet ou pics dans le but
de mieux éduquer ou informer notre
jeunesse enfin le gouvernement a mis en
place le site internet intitulé je
protège mon enfant.gouv.fr qui vise à
informer et guider les parents quant à
l'utilisation d'Internet pour leurs
enfants
en outre selon l'étude et enfance de
2021 il est tellement de constater que
83% des parents ignorent véritablement
ce que leur enfant font en ligne et que
57% d'entre eux n'utilisent pas de
dispositif de contrôle parental de ce
fait un groupe de parlementaires soutenu
par la secrétaire des tâches de
l'enfance charlotte cobel a créé le
campus des parents ainsi que la première
journée nationale des parents connectés
le 16 juillet afin de diffuser une
première série de vidéos éducatives pour
aider à sensibiliser les parents aux
outils de protection en ligne des
adolescents en définitive il est
essentiel d'améliorer la protection des
mineurs sur internet en particulier sur
les réseaux sociaux qui de nos jours
contribuent à la propagation de fausses
informations de contenu pornographiques
et de cyber-harcèlement cette commission
mixte paritaire conclusive marque la fin
de 4 mois de débat et de navette
parlementaires avec un vrai texte
significatif et prometteur qui protégera
enfin réellement efficacement nos jeunes
sur les réseaux sociaux à l'article
premier la définition des réseaux
sociaux sera inscrit dans la loi pour la
confiance dans l'économie numérique
tandis que l’arcome se verra confier la
compétence d'autorité régulatrice à
l'article 1 bis complète l'ère technique
initiale afin d'élargir le champ des
contenus illicites en incluant par
exemple les articles du Code pénal qui
constituent des délits il sera donc
impératif de pouvoir les signaler en
tant que tel sur les réseaux sociaux
l'article inter impose la diffusion
d'avertissement spécifique sur le
cyber-harcèlement l'article 2 coeur de
cette propulsion de loi instaure une
majorité numérique fixée à 15 ans par
conséquent les mineurs âgés de plus de
15 ans pour en s'inscrire sur réseaux
sociaux sans autorisation parentale en
revanche il impose aux plateformes
l'obligation de prendre des mesures pour
empêcher l'inscription des mineurs de 15
ans sauf autorisation explicite des
parents
de plus il permet aux parents de
demander la suppression du compte de son
enfant mineur et enfin il confie la com
après avis la CNIL le soin de certifier
les solutions techniques utilisées pour
vérifier l'âge ces solutions pourront
prendre la forme par exemple de
solutions tierces permettant une
vérification efficace de l'âge comme
c'est le cas pour bloquer les accès au
site pornographique comme l'a annoncé
notre ministre
l'article 3 quant à lui fixe un délai de
réponse aux réquisitions judiciaire pour
les plateformes il est fixé à 10 jours
pour toutes les réquisitions et à 8h en
cas d'atteinte grave aux personnes et au
bien je tiens tout de même à exprimer un
regret personnel mais aussi partager
dans cette émission quant à l'absence de
la mesure d'âge planché à 13 ans adopter
un premier lecture au sein de cette miss
cycle il s'agissait de définir un âge en
dessous duquel l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux était interdite comme cela est
le cas dans de nombreux primaires dans
de nombreux pays à l'instar des
États-Unis ou de la Chine comme il est
primordial de protéger efficacement nos
enfants le goût Renaissance votera en
faveur de ce texte de loi je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sophie blanc pour
le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame et Monsieur
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues après lecture dans les
deux chambres et une commission mixte
paritaire conclusive le moment est venu
de voter ce texte visant à instaurer une
majorité numérique et lutter contre la
haine en ligne cette loi sera une
première pièce elle est difficile que
nous avons bâtir pour que nos enfants
restent des enfants avec leur part de
rêve et d'innocence nous devons les
protéger autant que possible de la haine
en ligne et des dérives virales que les
réseaux sociaux peuvent répandre à une
vitesse qui nous dépasse celle
d'Internet et du haut débit qui serait
caché au fond d'un cartable d'écolier
plus de 3/4 des enfants entre 11 et 12
ans ont un compte sur un réseau social
et majoritairement sans aucun contrôle
parental le programme de Marine Le Pen
pour la dernière présidentielle proposée
déjà cette majorité numérique à l'âge de
15 ans mais aussi d'aller plus loin avec
l'intégration par défaut d'un contrôle
actif des contenus explicites par les
fournisseurs d'accès et par l'obligation
de communiquer un numéro de carte
bancaire pour accéder à certains
contenus cette loi tout de même posé des
garde-fous l'obligation de
l'autorisation d'un parent pour ouvrir
un compte sur les réseaux sociaux avant
l'âge de 15 ans et c'est une bonne
mesure la pression mise sur les
fournisseurs de services de réseaux
sociaux pour leur faire respecter cet
âge limite est également bénéfique car
une loi sans sanction est un voeu pieux
du législateur mais nous devons être
vigilants concernant la capacité de la
justice à agir face à des entreprises de
taille mondiale le temps judiciaire on
le sait n'est pas celui de l'urgence nos
enfants dans leur poche des téléphones
bien plus puissants que les ordinateurs
que nous utilisions à l'orage
l'irruption de la violence souvent
inattendue et toujours gratuite provoque
chez nos enfants des effets que la
médecine n'a pas fini d'étudier cette
fascination parfois malsaine pour les
écrans l'addiction qu'elle provoque nos
représentent pas uniquement un danger au
regard du traumatisme lié visionnage des
images subies mais déclenche aussi chez
les adolescents un enfermement dans un
monde virtuel qu'il aimait à la merci de
n'importe quel prédateur sévissant sur
le web
l'exposition des plus jeunes à des
images pornographiques qui fait aussi
naturellement partie des facteurs de la
destruction de cette innocence doit être
un sujet de vigilance pour les parents
c'est pourquoi nous devons aussi nous
poser la question de l'accompagnement de
ces derniers la haine et la violence des
jeunes sur les réseaux sociaux ne sont
pas qu'un problème d'âge ou de majorité
ils sont d'abord et avant tout un
problème d'éducation éducation des
parents pour contrôler les accès de
leurs jeunes enfants au réseau ils sont
encore près de 80% à déclaré ignorer ce
que ces derniers font sur leur téléphone
portable ils doivent expliquer les
méfaits de la quasi immortalité des
images qui restent éternellement sur le
web c'est pourquoi il nous appartient de
sensibiliser les parents sur le danger
de l'absence de contrôle et sur le
visionnage des images qui peuvent
choquer des cerveaux d'enfants en pleine
construction mentale posséder et
transmettre cette vigilance non pas sur
l'utilisation de l'informatique mais sur
son utilisation malveillante et sur les
effets dévastateurs de la virtualité
couplé à la viralité et à l'effet de
meute nous avons acquis la culture du
risque de l'exposition au soleil sans
protection de la même manière acquérant
celle de l'exposition aux écrans
contrôlons le temps que nos enfants y
passent et vérifions qu'ils sont autant
que possible protégés des contenus les
plus choquants et des réseaux tant
qu'ils n'en ont pas l'âge nous devons
aussi nous poser la question de la
pédagogie dont doit user le corps
professoral sur ces sujets cette
nouvelle dimension d'Internet et des
réseaux sociaux doit être intégrés dans
le cursus de formation des enseignants
du primaire et du secondaire ainsi que
dans celui des cours qu'il dispense
l'ordinateur connecté prend une place de
plus en plus importante dans la manière
dont les élèves apprennent travaillent
cherchent de l'information mais aussi
malheureusement harcèle
réponse et humilie ce texte est un bon
texte il pose les problèmes les noms
tentent de les résoudre et ouvre la voie
d'une attention accrue du Parlement à
ces sujets sensibles et très rapidement
évolutif de la protection de l'enfance
nous le voterons en l'espoir qu'il soit
le premier de nouveaux volets de la
politique de l'enfant et tout en nous
souvenant que les parents sont les
principaux acteurs de ce pan de
l'éducation face au danger de la haine
en ligne ce sont eux qui doivent
continuellement sensibiliser et protéger
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Ségolène Amiot
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
si vous me permettez j'aimerais tout
d'abord exprimer toutes mes condoléances
et mon profond soutien à la famille de
Naël et à l'ensemble de ses proches et
toute personne qui se sent intimement
touchés par ce drame
chers collègues cette proposition de loi
vise à lutter contre la haine en ligne
une haine des uns envers les autres qui
mènent à une peur des uns envers les
autres
ce texte est une tentative lancée pour
apporter une réponse à l'accès des
mineurs au vastes univers que sont
internet et les réseaux sociaux
mais nous sommes passés à côté d'une
protection effective par l'interdiction
pure et simple des réseaux au moins de
13 ans
ces plateformes en ligne sont un vecteur
de transmission des messages haineux les
plus souvent publiés par des personnes
cachées derrière leur VPN ou de faux
comptes et il est difficile voir
impossible pour les parents de protéger
totalement leurs enfants
l'inscription sur les réseaux sur un
réseau social est interdite avant 15 ans
selon la loi et bien souvent interdite
avant 13 ans par les plateformes
elles-mêmes des réseaux sociaux pourtant
selon une enquête de bornes sociaux les
11 et 12 ans sont 87% à utiliser
régulièrement au moins une application
liée à un réseau social l'étude indique
même que ce taux monte à 93%
spécifiquement chez les enfants de 12
ans
à noter qu'il existe un lien
qu'il existe un lien certain entre la
dégradation de la santé mentale des
jeunes et les réseaux sociaux en
particulier pour les jeunes filles
la majorité numérique est donc une
solution indispensable dont cette
proposition de loi n'apporte qu'une
réponse partielle on peut craindre que
cela ne suffise pas sans compter le fait
que les parents pourront déroger à cette
règle et autoriser une inscription plus
précoce sans aucune limite d'âge
les délais d'entrée en vigueur
relativement long sont le signe que le
gouvernement n'a pas pris la mesure de
l'urgence de réguler l'accès aux réseaux
sociaux on peut regretter une vision
étroite de la protection des mineurs
face aux dangers d'internet et les
illusoire de croire que la technique ou
l'interdiction peut remplacer
l'éducation aux usages numériques
ces derniers temps internet et les
réseaux sociaux ont atteint un niveau
inégalé de n en ligne des publications
et des commentaires insultants blessants
et choquants sont publiés en permanence
sur toutes les plateformes par des
citoyens des personnalités publiques et
même des politiques
le climat délétère dans lequel se trouve
la France aujourd'hui a créé une hausse
évidente de haine envers les plus
précaires les activistes pacifistes les
personnes LGBT qui a plus les musulmans
les Juifs les minorités et celles et
ceux qui ne correspondraient pas aux
critères définis par le plus grand
nombre
la liberté de la parole haineuse sans
aucune réponse efficace de la part du
gouvernement participe à cette
augmentation inquiétante de propos
discriminants et insultants c'est dans
ce contexte que cette proposition de loi
a été déposée par le rapporteur Marc
Angeli et je ne peux que saluer cette
initiative malheureusement la violence
symbolique du gouvernement nette pas à
lutter contre la haine qu'elle soit en
ligne ou non
lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron trouve 10 offres
d'emploi sur le port de Marseille il
insulte volontairement les derniers
cordées comme il l'a toujours fait
lorsque Gérald Darmanin dissout un
mouvement écologiste pacifiste sans
aucune réforme profonde de la police
républicaine il provoque une montée de
haine et un clivage toujours plus grand
entre les Français
lorsque Elisabeth borne active le 49-3
pour la 11e fois en un an elle crée un
sentiment profond d'incompréhension et
de rejet des institutions dans le cœur
des citoyens français
face à cette hausse de la haine des uns
envers les autres nous sommes plus que
mobilisés sur la nécessité de lutter
plus activement contre le
cyber-harcèlement et les plus largement
et plus largement les super délits ce
texte
issu de la commission mixte paritaire
contient 3 amendements du Sénat presque
identiques à ce que nous avions déposé
et défendu lors des discussions en
première lecture dans cette émission
rejetez ici mais adopter en Sénat et
conserver lors de la CMP il concerne
l'information de l'utilisation sur les
risques liés aux usages numériques les
moyens de les prévenir mais aussi la
délivrance aux mineurs d'une information
claire et adaptée des conditions
d'utilisation de leur donner et de leurs
droits Informatiques et Libertés enfin
un dernier amendement a permis
d'intégrer un dispositif permettant de
contrôler et notifier le temps
d'utilisation de ces plateformes
face à ces petites avancées nécessaires
nous voterons pour ce texte mais nous ne
nous arrêterons pas là il faut aller
plus loin notamment dans l'éducation aux
médias et à la responsabilisation des
comportements haineux il faut donner les
moyens nécessaires à l'arcom la CNIL et
l'éducation nationale pour donner à
chacune et chacun les moyens chevaux
défendre en ligne je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Maximino pour
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
Madame et Monsieur les ministres
mes chers collègues
le récent drame de vendeuil-le-vieil
dans lequel l'Insee jeune fille de 13
ans victime de harcèlement dans son
collège et sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
donner la mort nous rappelle à tous de
quoi les réseaux sociaux sont capables
dans le plus mauvais sens et si besoin
était l'urgence d'agir avec ce texte il
s'agit de protéger les enfants des
dangers que représente pour eux un usage
incontrôlé des réseaux sociaux danger
dont de nombreux drames comme celui de
l'Insee témoignent de la gravité la
crise sanitaire et les nombreux
confinements qui se sont succédés n'ont
fait que renforcer le pouvoir des
réseaux sociaux c'est le cas plus
particulièrement chez les jeunes qui ont
fait de leurs besoins d'être vu et
reconnus une obsession au point
malheureusement de modifier leur
comportement et de subir les
conséquences d'une société numérique
basée principalement sur le paraître
notre époque est témoin de l'émergence
des réseaux sociaux qui a fortement
transformé les relations humaines et le
rapport à la société notamment chez les
adolescents cette révolution numérique
est en oeuvre peut difficilement être
arrêtée mais peut-être en revanche
régulée c'est ce que l'on tente de faire
sur ce texte les constats sur lesquels
reposent cette proposition de loi sont
formelles mauvaises santé mentale manque
de confiance en soi trouble de la
personnalité dépression les mots les
plus présents au sein de notre société
et notamment chez les adolescents n'ont
fait que s'intensifier depuis
l'apparition des réseaux sociaux
face à ces constats nous partageons les
objectifs de la proposition de loi et
nous voyons à quel point le numérique a
envahi notre quotidien et combien il
faut réguler l'accès aux mineurs aux
réseaux sociaux nous constatons chaque
jour l'ampleur du défi à relever l'État
doit jouer pleinement son rôle il doit
contribuer avec les prérogatives qui
sont les siennes à l'épanouissement
intellectuel et social des adolescents
et cela passe bien évidemment par pour
nous par l'imposition de règles et de
contrôle a commencé par l'instauration
d'une majorité numérique pour accéder
aux réseaux sociaux prévus par ce texte
et dont nous nous réjouissons
nous devons articuler le droit autour de
la prévention de la protection et de la
pédagogie nous saluons la possibilité
donnée à un seul titulaire de l'autorité
parentale d'autoriser l'inscription de
son enfant sur un réseau social la
jurisprudence abondante en la matière
engendre des contentieux entre parents
et Paris et l'autorisation donnée à un
seul titulaire d'autorité parentale
semble d'ailleurs mieux correspondre à
la réalité
s'agissant d'un acte bien évidemment
usuel cela constitue tout de même un
premier garde-fou nous nous interrogions
grandement sur la responsabilité des
plateformes la première rédaction de la
PPL ne mentionnait nulle part les
modalités de vérification de l'âge ni la
nature des pénalités permettant de
sanctionner le manque d'implication à la
matière des fournisseurs nous le
constatons sur les sites notamment
existants accessibles uniquement aux
personnes majeures il est aisé notamment
pour une génération maîtrisant
parfaitement l'outil numérique de
déjouer les règles il est donc
primordial de responsabiliser les
fournisseurs de réseaux sociaux et de
leur imposer une auto régulation
la rédaction actuelle du texte crée la
possibilité de mettre en demeure ces
fournisseurs dès lors qu'il ne se
présentent pas une qui ne présente pas
une solution technique certifiée de
vérification de l'âge de même il sera
possible au président de l'arcom de
saisir le président du tribunal
administratif enfin les sanctions
financières sont des armandes prévues en
cas de non-respect de ses obligations
toutes ces inventes c'est représentent
l'essence même de la responsabilité de
législateur être à la fois un lanceur
d'alerte un créateur de cadre juridique
et un garde-fou de l'application de
celui-ci
bien évidemment nous avons conscience
que cette proposition de loi est le seul
ne changera pas tout du jour au
lendemain
mais elle ne réglera effectivement comme
je vous disais pas tous les problèmes
d'un coup mais cependant une avancée
reste une avancée qui amènera l'État et
l'Union européenne notamment à
intervenir sur le sujet c'est pourquoi
le groupe des Républicains votera donc
favorablement pour ce texte
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent est-ce
que négoce pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
la présidence madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue je me réjouis
que nous puissions voter en ce jour
c'est important avancé avec ce texte
nous inscrivons en effet dans les
actions menées depuis 2017 pour protéger
les plus jeunes face aux dérives de la
vie et d'ici face à celle du numérique
aussi je souhaiterais saluer tout
particulièrement les avancées de ce
texte en matière de lutte contre le
harcèlement mon groupe était très
impliqué sur ce sujet notamment au
travers de la loi de mon collègue
Erwan Balanant et nous venons ici
utilement complété son action la
République devait cette loi à ses
enfants face à la montée de la haine en
ligne de la laine de soie et du rejet de
l'autre la représentation nationale ne
pouvait rester les bras ballants les
chiffres sont dramatiques un enfant sur
cinq a déjà été confronté aussi bien
harcèlement ce sont près de 2 millions
de nos fils filles ou petits enfants qui
connaissent l'enfer d'être rejeté par
jalousie ven ou parce que simplement
différent en cette fin de mois des
fierté rappelons-nous d'ailleurs des
particulières violences qui touchent les
LGBTI plus deux fois plus harcelé que la
moyenne et avec une probabilité trois
fois plus grande d'être attaquée sur les
réseaux sociaux ces jeunes souffrent
cette souffrance conduit à des drames
des drames que la société n'a
malheureusement pas su éviter ces
tragédie nous rappelle la puissance
dangereuse des outils du numérique alors
que la sonnerie de fin de classe a
longtemps constitué l'annonce d'un répit
pour un jeune harcelé le basculement
environnement de physico digital à
paradoxalement renforcer l'isolement de
ceux qui se sentaient déjà bien trop
seuls pourtant la promesse du
développement d'Internet et des réseaux
sociaux était belle celle d'un monde
connecté permet dans un partage infini
des connaissances nous faisons pas
d'ailleurs du monde numérique un mouton
noir capable du pire et incapable de
permettre le meilleur car le malgré leur
dérive les réseaux sociaux restent une
source d'information d'échanges et de
découverte
ils permettent à des jeunes de créer de
nouveaux liens de se rendre compte
qu'ils ne sont pas seuls et que d'autres
leur ressemblent c'est donc cet
équilibre qu'il est nécessaire de
trouver entre protection et liberté des
mineurs le groupe démocrate se réjouit
que votre texte monsieur le rapporteur
et rapidement trouver cette équilibre au
travers d'un dispositif principal qui
permettra aux parents de retrouver une
juste place dans l'accès mais parfois
aussi dans les excès de leurs enfants
dans le numérique en évitant de tomber
dans la caricature d'un contrôle
permanent en dessous de la majorité
civique vous avez su éviter le piège de
infantilisation notre jeunesse au
contraire fixer à 15 ans cet âge minimal
c'est permettre une responsabilisation
croissante qui coupait un renforcement
de l'éducation numérique que nous
appelons de nos vœux est nécessaire à
l'émancipation d'une jeunesse éclairée
les dispositifs ajoutés au Sénat comme
sur l'information sur le temps
d'utilisation contribue à donner aux
parents les clés pédagogiques d'un suivi
attentif sans être intrusif des premiers
pas numériques de leurs enfants nous
saluons ces avancées surtout le groupe
démocrate se félicite du caractère
extrêmement concret de ce texte loin de
se contenter de déclaration de principes
certes belle sur le papier mais sans
effet sur les réels dangers les
expérimentations en cours permettront
une mise en œuvre rapide
bien sûr sur certains sujets le groupe
démocrate aurait aimé aller plus loin
nous regrettons notamment que
l'amendement que j'avais fait adopter
ici pour une fusion entre les numéros de
soutien contrôleur harcèlement le 30/20
et le si belharcèlement le 30 18 était
supprimé au Sénat des sénateurs ont
également soutenu cette solution et je
les en remercie
cette piste d'amélioration ne doit
toutefois pas cacher les grands progrès
pour la lutte contre la haine en ligne
que va également permettre cette loi
d'abord grâce à l'adoption à l'assemblée
de nouvel article 1 bis porté par la
délégation des droits aux femmes
permettant de mieux appréhender les
atteintes à la représentation à la vie
privée et à la sécurité des personnes
ensuite grâce au vote de l'amendement
que j'avais pu porter au nom du groupe
démocrate imposant aux plateformes de
mettre en avant les numéros d'aide
contrôleur harcèlement et de les
afficher en cas de signalement
ces dispositions permettra aux jeunes de
savoir immédiatement que des numéros
d'urgence soit à leur disposition prêts
à les écouter et prêts à les aider pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe démocrate
votera résolument et avec enthousiasme
le texte très attendu et je sais
Monsieur le Ministre que nous acterons
encore de belles avancées à la rentrée
avec ce projet de loi visant à sécuriser
et réguler et réguler pardon l'espace
numérique et que nous attendons avec
impatience je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
sur le vote de l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi je suis saisie par le
groupe Renaissance et par le groupe
horizon d'une demande de scrutin public
scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Monsieur
ignyaki et Shanice pour le groupe
socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame
monsieur les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue le groupe
socialiste au nom duquel je m'exprime
aujourd'hui a toujours eu à coeur de
mener tout combat contre la haine et les
dangers en ligne en particulier
lorsqu'il frappe notre jeunesse chacun
le sait les enfants sont massivement
connectés au réseau sociaux et ce de
plus en plus tôt selon la CNIL les
premières inscriptions et un réseau
social surviendrait à 8 ans et demi et
63% des moins de 3 ans ont un minimum un
compte sur les réseaux sociaux si les
conditions générales d'utilisation
étaient respectées il ne pourrait en
réalité pas y accéder aussi il est
important de noter que l'activité en
ligne des enfants et assez peu contrôlé
par leurs parents 80% déclarent ne pas
avoir ne pas savoir exactement ce que
leurs enfants font sur les réseaux
sociaux ces chiffres sont d'autant plus
inquiétants quand on mesure les
conséquences déjà dites ici de la
présence excessive des enfants devant un
écran et sur les réseaux sociaux fatigue
excessive rythme des ajustés stress
addiction trouble et retraits
relationnels
activité accroître les risques de
harcèlement de dépression ou des
expositions à des contenus
pornographiques cette situation nous
imposait de renforcer notre vigilance
sur la consommation des réseaux sociaux
et de mettre un terme à la trop faible
régulation des plateformes en les
responsabilisant davantage ce texte va
dans le bon sens et présente des
avancées qui suivent la logique d'un
plus d'un plus grand encadrement
concernant la haine en ligne et d'une
actualisation de la réglementation
notamment après la loi du 21 juin 2004
pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique qui prévoit d'imposer aux
acteurs du secteur de lutter contre la
diffusion d'apologie de crimes contre
l'humanité l'incitation à la haine
raciale ainsi que la pornographie
infantine je tiens ici à souligner les
améliorations apportées sur ce texte
grâce au travail de notre assemblée et
de nos collègues sénateurs
s'il vous plaît on écoute le dernier
orateur je vous remercie lors du
précédent passage de cette proposition
de loi nous avions déjà permis
d'identifier l'absence de dispositif de
vérification que ça soit l'âge de
l'enfant ou du consentement du parent et
d'y remédier avec l'obligation pour les
fournisseurs de services de réseaux
sociaux de mettre en place une solution
technique
elle vise à contrôler l'âge des
personnes présentes nouveaux
utilisateurs ou déjà inscrits de
recueillir l'éventuelle autorisation des
titulaires de l'autorité parentale pour
les mineurs âgés de 13 à 15 ans et de
respecter le cadre national et européen
sur la protection des données
personnelles puis contraignant pour les
mineurs la mise en place de cette
solution suppose donc la création d'un
dispositif conçu en fonction des
critères de l'arcom et Deck et de la
CNIL en cas de non respect de cette
obligation le réseau social pourra se
voir infliger une amende jusqu'à 1% de
son chiffre d'affaires mondial ce qui
permet de rendre cette loi contraignante
pour les plateformes nous vous alertions
également sur le fait que l'instauration
de cette majorité numérique ne peut
s'appliquer sans informer les mineurs de
leurs droits tels que tel que leur
demander la CNIL c'est désormais sur
chose faite l'article 2 prévoit
d'améliorer l'information des mineurs
inscrit sur l'utilisation de leur donnée
personnelle et des risques liés aux
usages numériques je salue également
l'alinéa prévoyant l'obligation
d'information des utilisateurs et des
parents lors de l'inscription sur les
risques liés aux usages numériques et
les moyens de prévention
le projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique nous offrira
à ce titre l'occasion de parler de ce
sujet de manière plus générale pour
protéger nos enfants je vous remercie je
vous remercie
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au voile
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi je
vous prie de bien vouloir gagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 1811
exprimé 191 majorité 96 pour 191 contre
0 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]